the great chris farley from saturday
night live was your best man
he was i didn't know you had a close
relationship with him he heeded a
depression of b
and uh uh victoria jackson did roseanne
on
saturday night live they said our tattoo
was on our butt and that is a lie
our tattoo is right here this is not our
butt dennis
that is not our boss but it's not our
part yeah we saw that obviously we were
we loved it and and uh we were going out
there to co-host a show or something
and laura michaels called me says you
have a lot in common with chris farley
would you please spend time with him you
know he wanted to be sober
and i think lord really worried about
that and so i was his sponsor for
a few years oh wow and uh we we travel
i mean chris is from wisconsin i'm from
iowa we go to
switch off football games very close
when he came out to do my
television show or my hbo specials he
just knew how fun he was
but then he'd stay with me and i got to
know his whole family and you know he'd
like to
have fun and uh you know he had he had
too much fun
very sad when he died it must have
driven you crazy that you couldn't stop
him from
abusing himself he went to 17. he was on
his way to his 17th rehab
it's also frustrating because at a
certain point that he's like yeah i'm
not going to be around tom because i
don't want
him to see i always told chris you can't
be fat
and do drugs you just can't be that bad
you got to pick one and i know i fee
speak from experience right pick one you
just can't do
everything you're running the risk of a
heart attack pretty quickly it's too
much on your body
did farley throw you a bachelor party
because i would imagine
it had to be complete debauchery if if
there was one no it wasn't we did it
it uh scores and then what happened was
uh
all the guys david spade was at the
wedding there was a lot of guys that
finally disappeared
and then came on stage naked and then
they ended up
kicking everybody out i mean because he
was a big guy he did not mind being
naked chris farley gets on the stripper
stage
and removes all his clothing and starts
dancing that's unbelievable i mean what
a commitment to comedy did he have a big
dick that he was willing to do that or
was it it was good enough
it wasn't baldick for sure but he had so
much i mean you remember the
the patrick swayze the dancing on
saturday night live with the body thing
and he called me that week
and he said i am so embarrassed they
wrote me this thing and
it's embarrassed because i'll be the fat
guy next to patrick swayze
what do you think and i said i think it
if you could be the funniest fat guy
ever doing this thing then you should do
it and you should really go for it but
he also
he was naked a lot wow barley would be
taken there's no
there's no shame in his game